un milieu où la reine est importante il
y a des gens sont là par attachement à
la reine Elizabeth II et moins à la
monarchie
pour pour moi comme une femme
le Canada et le seul pays du commonwald
qui a rendu hommage à la reine lors
d'une cérémonie officielle tenue en
présence de 600 dignitaires à la
cathédrale Chrysler
l'ancien Premier ministre Brian a
souligné l'engagement de la souveraine
envers le bilinguisme et le fait
français au Canada sont richesse
inestimable pour le rôle unique joué par
les Canadiens français
dans l'avancement du Québec moderne
[Musique]
pour le Canada pour les Canadiens et à
travers ses 70 années de règne elle
représenter
une certaine stabilité à travers les
bons et les moments alors nous on est là
merci on pensait ils sont avec sa
famille et nous sommes très
reconnaissants de sa service
[Musique]
au Canada même à la fin de sa vie elle
était là pour pour faire son devoir
au début d'un nouveau règne où Charles
III devra faire sa place celui
d'Elisabeth II restera pour beaucoup de
Canadiens un symbole de dévouement et de
dignité
[Musique]
ici Louis Blouin Radio-Canada
Ottawa